there's only one spider-man all right we
got past symbiote invasion scenario
number three and now we can move on to
something not related to space aliens
made of evil skin this time spider-man
is hopping dimensions meaning we have
four different spider-man's four uh
Spider Men yeah
the original spider-man breaks some
mystical tablet in the universe will
collapse if he doesn't hot glue it back
together with the help of three other
Spidey's from alternate universes
how many spider men does it take to
screw in a light bulb
for apparently one to actually do it two
to make bad jokes about it and the
fourth to get beaten to death and
replaced by a minority with cooler
superpowers the story was written by a
writer from the comics Dan Slott who is
inspired to later write a series called
spider-verse with a very similar premise
to this game it's always better when a
writer for the books does the story on
these things they know what they're
doing this is the first game in a long
time developed by someone other than
Treyarch who were reassigned to working
on call of duty because Activision's
priorities are fall so be knox got the
spider-man license Oh fun they
previously did a Guitar Hero game and
some tie ins for DreamWorks movies which
doesn't inspire confidence but will give
the newbies a try anyway we have the
regular Spider Man noir ultimate and
2099 all of which are played by the
voice actors from each spider-man
cartoon from the past 20 years Neil
Patrick Harris plays amazing Peter
Parker and my favorite Josh Keaton Oh
spectacular spider-man is ultimately
what am i doing in the black suit I hate
this thing one thing that bothers me is
that we still have the black suit in
this game somehow it's a silly little
cop-out they use to differentiate
between amazing and ultimate other than
height they say ultimate Peter is the
youngest and the weakest so Madame web
grants him a black suit on a leash to
make up for it thankfully his original
suit is an unlockable costume so you can
just wear that if it bothers you that
much this one structured different than
I'm used to I guess I'll go over
everything in the game overall and then
talk about the four variants of
spider-man individually this game is
totally linear and has no open-world
which upset me when I first heard about
it but as I thought more on it it's a
welcome change of pace we've seen an
open-world version of New York four
times in a row now and that one makes
sense for this story unless they model
for variations of New York one in the
1940s to current ones that look
different somehow
and a sprawling cyberpunk metropolis
with five hundred story buildings they
made the right choice the linear design
doesn't detract from the experience and
each of the characters has a distinct
style based on the art of their
individual books all versions have a
pretty standard character action game
combat system a lock-on allied attack a
strong attack whoa really breaking the
mold there guys the web strike thing is
still here but it's far less effective
and far less fun there's a weird clunky
annoying first-person fighting mode that
it forces you to use on occasion yes way
I mean that I seen one of these before
no you haven't
I am I totally have they once again have
way too many stupid spider tokens for
you to collect but unlike the last game
they're much easier to find and you go
oh I guess I'll grab that one why not
right then you think the same thing for
the next one you see
and then you think the same thing for
the next one then it happens again then
you black out and realize to eight hours
have passed and you've obsessively found
all 385 of them web-swinging is sort of
pointless but it controls well and you
can zip to purch points and walk on
balance beams movement is just just as
justice as it's fine just it's fine
really the overall gameplay is sort of
standard and boring get the interesting
parts line the details and variations of
the spider-man cz's ultimate spiderman
contains the same cel-shaded art style
of the other game and has the best
missions in this game the black suit
gives them a rage meter that he can
fight Fords of enemies with so like
spider-man 3 but not spider-man 3 which
means it's good the mission ray goes on
the set of a twisted game show on an oil
rig is my favorite the host of this
mission is none other than get a Hero
for Hire mask for your test the guy who
won't die
in the back and forth between them is so
fun to listen to
did you seriously just try to lock me in
a room what am i grounded it just sit
tight my little mouth-breather we got to
pause for another break from our sponsor
this mission has the most exploration
and some larger environments being that
you can't leave an area until you found
and destroyed every camera on the oil
rig all of the bad guys are dead pools
obsessive fans look at these losers
dressed up in Deadpool merchandise who
the [ __ ] dresses like that oh um no one
North reprises his role as the hero
whose superpowers murder and he never
fails his Deadpool hey he died baby died
good but but but the third mission as
ultimate Spidey has him fighting the
ultimate universes carnage a horrible
and monstrous spaghetti clone of Peter
he had very little screen time in the
game ultimate spider-man but that
mission still gave me nightmares as a
kid it was my favorite boss and this
offers a bit of nostalgia for me he /
she / it doesn't have as much
personality as the original carnage but
it's still a fun fight and the setting
of the mission is by far the biggest and
scale with an entire Helicarrier
crashing behind you I just wish he
wasn't wearing that damn overyou suit
all time and now you must all return to
your own dimensions
see you later older and less cool
versions of me
noir universe I'm saying that correctly
right doir nor nor contains a spider-man
who talks like a 1940's wiseguy and
beats up stereotypical Italian mobsters
I didn't think there could be a
spider-man more edgy than renegade
spider-man but here he is he's trying so
hard to be Batman which translates to
the Arkham like gameplay you have to be
like a spider ninja because he can't
take a bullet to save his life
wait isn't that a bit of a contradiction
no not the weird phrasing of that
sentence I mean ultimate Spidey
was the weakest and got the black suit
to make up for it but this spider-man
can be beaten in a hand-to-hand fight by
a normal human being but yeah give this
loser the black suit wait then he'd be
too edgy that amount of darkness and
renegade would end all life as we know
it so I have to stick to the shadows
don't worry I'll be stealthier than kate
mara and Jamie Bell at Comic Con this
Joker topical as of August 5th 2015
while the stealth attacks aren't as
varied as they could be it's still very
satisfying to make it through a whole
section without being spotted the art
style and stealth gameplay sets this one
apart from the others and I like how
varied it is from the usual style of
Spider Man punching first and asking
questions later okay spider-man 2099 has
the best setting it's like spider-man in
Blade Runner the buildings are so tall
he can just stop swinging and fall for
minutes without hitting the ground this
one isn't very different in terms of
gameplay or play style but man is it fun
to look at the environments are so huge
and detailed this Spider Man didn't have
many villains so like Spider Man noir
the game invents new villains for them
which are all welcomed additions and
make for a lot of fresh ideas well you
did have some good villains but all of
them are futuristic variations of other
characters and
imagine it would confuse people to have
two vultures and to venom symbiotes
having read the spider-man 2099 series
and being a huge fan of that character
I'm kind of bothered by a lot of the
choices made in the development of this
segment in the game it ignores a lot of
lore and characters to keep it simple
but come on they couldn't use at least
one bin joke how about the mission where
you break into alchemax it could I have
a scene where you talk to the evil CEO
of the company Aaron stone who is also
Miguel O'Hara's spoiler skip to this
timecode if you haven't read it and want
to dad just have him say something
snarky over the intercom so when we know
that he exists I don't know the biggest
issue for me is the costume that Miguel
O'Hara wears there replaces big dumb
todd mcfarlane cape with a wingsuit
design and of course the whole thing is
the complete wrong color now you may be
asking Xavier what are you talking about
it looks great well no it's blue and it
shouldn't be you hear me out on this
okay Miguel O'Hara suit is actually
black if you read the book they talk
about the guy in the black suit all the
time it's referenced every five minutes
the reason it looks blue is a limitation
of the art style new york and 84 years
is a mess of neon lights and it's hard
to communicate brightness on pitch black
textures and drawings so they use blue
to accent it and black as the parts that
aren't coated and white instead of black
being the shadow like everyone thought
it was they used the same trick to draw
venom in tons of cases to this little
inconsistency leads me to wonder if the
devs actually looked at the books in
depth or just took some quick glances at
Google Image Search and said just design
it based off this without getting any
context of the way things look or why
they are the way they are it's a minor
thing that no one but an insane person
with OCD would complain about but to me
it shows a bit of laziness in the
creative process I even have a Halloween
costume that's the right color
Miguel O'Hara's costume design is a
massive misconception based on no one
having actually read the book except for
me and some guy from Idaho God do I
sound enough like a hipster the final
boss of the game is when Mysterio gains
godlike powers and starts tearing apart
the universes which means all of the
different spider-man have to fight him
one at a time and once they finally beat
him they only get one scene to interact
with each other I couldn't help but
notice noir spider-man segment of this
boss fight is exactly like a scene in
Arkham hide behind the ruins suspended
and impossible space and avoid the
spotlight if they've been any more
unsubtle with this one is that a cartoon
pig focus ironically the most boring
segments of this game are about the
original spider-man he has Kraven
Sandman and juggernaut his bosses these
missions feel so drawn-out and the color
palette is so boring to look at we've
been this same spider-man so many times
before that all you want to do is give
the other guys a try only the original
one had somewhere more interesting to go
like accidentally falling into the
settings of the other three variations
and having to interact with them it
would be so much more interesting this
game in general has gameplay that isn't
anything special but the art styles
clever writing an imaginative concept
I'll make this one worth a try for fans
of the character it just doesn't capture
that feeling of being spider-man though
you'd rather be spider-man in the future
or the past
anything but the normal one oh come on
Marty you gotta come back with me we're
back to the future